hello all you transphobes you bigots you
monsters you terrible people I have been
informed by Tick Tock that if you are a
fella and you don't want to go on a date
with a fella in a dress you're a very
very bad person let's hear the arguments
okay Kirk that's transphobic I can get
on board with people having preferences
I can even kind of get on board with
people having genital preferences
although I think that's stupid but if
you're refusing to date a trans woman
because you're afraid not because you're
not attracted to her not because you
don't enjoy who she is as a person then
I strongly encourage you to investigate
how systemic transphobia has influenced
your dating preferences like just do it
um that was really bad if you're afraid
of dating the guy who thinks that he's a
woman and you are afraid in a way that
is irrational I guess that would be
transphobia that's just the definition
of transphobia if that word has any
meaning at all but if you are afraid say
that uh for a guy to date a guy who
wears a dress that that transgresses the
moral law or if you are most likely not
afraid in any way you're just sort of
disgusted by that very thought or if you
believe that man is a coupling being and
men and women are complementary and that
they go together and that the purpose of
dating is then to get married and
marriage is a lifelong Union between a
husband and a wife for the good of the
spouses and the sake of the generation
of Education children I'm just throwing
that out there that seems like it would
be a pretty good reason what if you just
object to it why is it always fear I'm
afraid that Society might look down on
me dating this confused man I'm afraid
that I don't know that he's a man I
don't know exactly why can't you just
object to it why can't you have a
natural revulsion at that concept or why
can't you have at least a logical a
rational uh understanding that this is
not what people are for men are not
supposed to date other men and even if
the men were addressed and pretend to be
women why can't you just object to
certain things very phobic the only
things you're allowed to object to are
things that are good and true and
traditional and beautiful okay next one
now dating trans people is not a
preference not dating blondes is a
preference not dating people who are I
don't know shorter than five six is a
preference not dating people with brown
eyes as a preference being trans is not
a specific characteristic
thus you can't label it as a preference
that's just called bigotry
no one's forcing you to date trans
people but don't cover up your
discriminatory bias in the name of
preference
because the logic doesn't add up like
I've said in many a video the logic of
transphobia never adds up there are some
deficiencies in logic I I will grant her
that in this whole phenomenon there is
definitely a dearth of logic about the
whole thing a lot of she says no one's
forcing you to date a trans person but
if you don't you're a bigger in your
discriminatory and you're probably fat
and stupid oh no one's forcing you to do
it
the point where I have to agree with her
though is she says look if you don't
want to date a blonde that's a
preference that's fine you don't want to
date a girl who's short that's a
preference that's fine but if you don't
want to date a trans person that's
that's totally different because being
trans is not a specific characteristic I
agree with that point entirely being
being trans is not real that's not an
ontological category that is real that's
a a euphemism to describe a sexual
delusion if you're a man and you say I
don't want to date a trans woman what
you're saying is I'm not a homosexual
and I would prefer to date a woman a
real woman and I'm sure these people
would tell you that that is bigotry
that's what she is saying she's saying
that if you have any distinction that
you draw between men and women that
that's bigoted and it's not only these
crazy transgender lunatics who are
talking about that it's the logic of
feminism or if you say that men and
women are meaningful meaningfully
different in any way that you're a bigot
it's not just the wackos on Tick Tock
that's a lot of our culture maybe the
majority of our culture certainly the
powerful institutions they're saying the
exact same thing the reveal parties
kind of transphobic I don't think it's
that difficult of a concept the grasp
you break it down to reveal parties are
about does baby have beep us or vajazzle
that's already a thing the JJ
I don't like any of those gender is a
sense of self that comes from the brains
and the leg situation the in between the
leggy situation
baby will figure out sense of self in
time baby we'll figure out how to
present themselves to World in time
revealing the genitalia of an infant
just feels really icky to me and as
parents it it implies hey I'm letting
the world know that I'm already going to
be implementing gender roles onto my
child and that really tends to
discourage the whole trans thing correct
and trans people exist there are plenty
other ways to celebrate New Life say a
baby shower a concept that already
exists we don't need to make up new
things but here's something we could try
we could try doing a gender reveal party
when somebody wants to come out let's
take a step away from the gender reveal
thing just to be a little bit more open
and welcoming to different identities
and experiences in life let's work
together two to better sorry lady
not interested no let's not let's be
much more closed off to those identities
and expressions and delusions our minds
are very open now in society our minds
are so open that our brains have fallen
out the argument this guy is making is
is pretty good actually he's not going
as far as some others do to pretend that
transgenderism is a biological
phenomenon he is still using materialist
physical terms like he says that sex is
what goes on between your legs and
gender is what happens in the brain but
I think to be charitable to his
[Music]
um
self-expression what he's talking about
is the mind he's saying your your sex is
what's going on with your body but your
gender is how you express your own
self-conception and self-identity of sex
out in the world it's how you perform
things he's obviously a rather
performative
thespian-minded sort of person and that
that's true but but the the way that the
transgenderists talk about it is they
say we need to give people the utmost
license to express sex in any way that
they want through any kind of
performance of gender but my question
then is why okay sex and gender
expression are distinct things yeah okay
in the case of a disagreement between
those things why do we need to bring the
sex into better alignment with the
gender expression why do we need to
mutilate the body why do we need to put
on the silly dresses why do we need to
put on the stilettos if your gender
expression is such that you're you are
really a man but you you perform that
you're a woman why wouldn't you just do
the opposite why wouldn't you say okay
I'm a man that's my sex but my gender
expression I really want to be like a
woman but I'm just not going to do that
I'm going to bring those two things into
alignment in the other direction well
this guy would say because you need to
be totally open why well because
what they don't have an answer to that
that's just their premise their premise
is that we need to ignore reality we
need to deny that things in the world
have a purpose just as this leftists
Tumblr as the purpose of getting you
left the stairs microphone has the
purpose of transmitting my dolphin noise
my body has a purpose those little
things going on between the legs as he
describes it have a purpose and and you
have a duty by virtue of your real
identity that can be perceived within
the real world you have a duty to act in
accordance with that it's a little bit
different than the way a lot of
conservatives in a squishier way talk
about this stuff they say well you know
you're biological mail you can change
your name to Caitlyn you can wear
dresses that's fine that's your right or
whatever but you just you're a
biological male and you need to admit
your biological sex no I don't I don't
think you have a right to wear dresses
if you're a man and that isn't the the
fashion and that's not what that symbol
represents I don't think you have a
right to chop your genitals off just
because you're deluded you have a right
to do any of that you gotta act like a
man
if you're a man what's the matter with
you I'm Michael Knowles Casino
[Music]
[Applause]